we're always devising special tools it's
part it's part of the joy of doing it as
I improvising a problem is a joy
sometimes there but love the time we
didn't have a lot of space for example
as he walks up the building and it the
room we were filming in was was only so
high so we did the obvious thing we put
the camera on its side and built the
whole set on its side now again this is
something we use time and time again
they the hilt sequence in loaf and death
which we'll see later because they're
going down a quite a steep hill now if
we built that as a full-sized set and it
would you know one end will be down
there what end will be up there and how
we get the animator up there and down
there in it so we put the whole hill on
that level and put the camera on the
slant it did mean all the buildings on
that hill are actually built on the
slant so but when ya when you actually
see a projected everything is that way
around so it's corrected so so it's on
the level the other thing as well which
is which goes back to the train chase
and the lorry chase is we recycle
because we build this set and we light
it and dress it in such a way that one
end of it and the other end are exactly
the same so basically as you're doing a
shot you go from there as you get to the
end you take it all back to the and
again and carry on it's an infinity set
it could go on forever and feels like it
is on some of the films because it it's
stretching reality but say you see that
hill is reciting the same things again
the train chase is reciting the lorry
sequence was recycling and also lack of
finance or suppose that reciting and the
blurred background meant and it didn't
cost us very much in terms of props and
his we'd use the same things over and
over again and in fact I think on the
lorry chase a if you look at that we
won't see it in the bathroom because it
is a blur I mean some of those blurs is
just a pile of old coats or something
which audition it's basic it's
impressionistic it's just texture and
color and which actually is better than
actually showing thing in great clarity
so that's another trick really it is an
impressionistic look of something rather
than go for that a full vision of what's
there and
as you would have seen here there's
painted background so everything was
pretty done in camera we mean there's a
little bit of optical work for the
lasers and things and on the wrong
trousers but everything else is shot in
camera so the force perspectives a lot
of scenic art and the background
background which which you kind of see
here but actually gives it rather nice
paint lee feel to it so they're quite a
basic practical tricks and actually
quite old cinema tricks I don't think
we're not on these films but you have
actually done hanging miniatures and
things before glass painting so going
back the old ways matter of life and
death is a little bit different we had
beauty shot digitally so he had a bit
more digital post in that but the three
films were very much shot in camera yeah
yeah this year as to say yeah wrong
trousers and no special effects at all
really as they just there's two simple
impositions a bit of rain which we shot
a watering can and the lasers and I
think there's just seven shots in
closure which you're about to see which
we did some post digital manipulation
otherwise all in camera and we always
try to keep it there as much in camera
as possible